Senator John Kennedy state of Louisiana
one of the hardest hit by the
coronavirus senator Kennedy joins us now
senator our thoughts and prayers with
the the people in the great state of
Louisiana why did we have Mardi Gras
number one and I know the president
announced these building triage
hospitals there and sending all the
supplies there what's the status of
things in Louisiana like most states
Sean we are catching fresh hell I don't
know why bad things happen to good
people if I make it to heaven I'm gonna
ask we are coping thanks primarily to
our our heroes and scrubs we've got the
best doctors and the best nurses and the
best health care professionals in the
universe our biggest worry my biggest
worry and I thank my colleagues shared
among many worries is ventilators we
have counting the ventilators that
President Trump sent to us we have about
1500 right now we have 507 of our people
on ventilators and and you you say well
you still got 2/3 of capacity yes but we
just don't know where this thing is
going we just don't know when we're
gonna hit the apex and start down the
other side of the hill so that's my
biggest worry right now are you in
contact with the president yes I spoke
to the president and the vice president
they were together in his office
yesterday we talked about the situation
in Louisiana we talked about the economy
including the oil and gas industry the
small business loan program that we
passed in our cares Act thanks to
Secretary of minuchin is going to start
at midnight tonight minuchin is sending
out checks through the IRS next week the
the Federal Reserve I think has set up
its facility to loan and they're not
bailouts they're loans to large
businesses I'm very worried about our
state
unemployment compensation programs I'm
really worried that it's not anybody's
fault that I just well I never want to
actually the response that they can
handle the volume Democrats didn't have
to push with it Kennedy Center national
endowment for the arts humanities and
delay all the aid would be getting there
sooner senator will praying for your
state whatever you need anything we can
do anything these Airways always open to
you and you're in our prayers tonight
everybody in the great state of
Louisiana